WE ARE FOLLOWING THIS PROMISING
NEW DEVELOPMENTS THAT THE
CORONAVIRUS PANDEMIC, INCLUDING
THE POSSIBILITY THAT AN
EXPERIMENTAL MEDICATION MAY
SOON GET EMERGENCY USE
AUTHORIZATION IN THE U.S..
JOINING US NOW, PRESIDENTS
CHIEF MEDICAL ADVISER, DOCTOR
ANTHONY FAUCI.
HE'S ALSO THE DIRECTOR OF THE
NATIONAL INSTITUTE OF ALLERGY
AND INFECTIOUS DISEASES.
DOCTOR FAUCI, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR JOINING US.
AS YOU KNOW, HOSPITALIZATIONS,
DEATHS AND CASES, THEY'RE ALL
DECLINING IN THE U.S. RIGHT
NOW.
AS THIS FINALLY THE END OF THE
DELTA SURGE IN THE U.S.?
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> WELL I HOPE SO, WOLF.
IT IS CERTAINLY GOING IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION, AS YOU
MENTIONED CORRECTLY THAT ALL
THE PARAMETERS, CASES,
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATHS ARE
DOWN.
THE CRITICAL CHALLENGE THAT WE
HAVE NOW, WE WANT TO KEEP THAT
SLOPE OF DECLINE CONTINUING TO
GO DOWN.
NOW, AS YOU KNOW, WE HAVE ABOUT
68 MILLION PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY WHO ARE ELIGIBLE TO BE
VACCINATED, OR NOT YET
VACCINATED.
THE BEST WAY TO BE SURE THAT
DECLINE, IN CASES,
HOSPITALIZATIONS, AND DEATHS TO
CONTINUE IS TO CONTINUE TO GET
A LOT MORE PEOPLE VACCINATED.
WE NEED AN OVERWHELMING
PROPORTION OF THOSE
UNVACCINATED PEOPLE TO GET
VACCINATED, AND THEN WE CAN BE
QUITE CONFIDENT THAT IF WE CAN
DO THAT, YOU WILL NOT SEE A
RESURGENCE.
IT REALLY DEPENDS UPON US, AND
OUR ABILITY TO RISE TO THE
OCCASION AND GET PEOPLE
VACCINATED.
>> HOW DO WE DO THAT?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, WE HAVE
OBVIOUSLY BEEN TRYING VERY
HARD.
WE'RE TRYING TO GET TRUSTED
MESSENGERS OUT THERE, AND
TRYING TO GET THIS AWAY FROM
BEING AN IDEOLOGICAL OR A
POLITICAL STATEMENT.
GET BACK INTO THE REALM OF PURE
PUBLIC HEALTH, AND TRY TO
CONVINCE PEOPLE --
BUT ALSO MANDATES, I MEAN, WE
DON'T LIKE TO BE TELLING PEOPLE
WHAT THEY NEED TO DO.
BUT WE KNOW THAT MANDATES WORK.
WE'VE SEEN THAT THEY ARE
WORKING.
THEY'RE WORKING IN SCHOOLS,
UNIVERSITIES, COLLEGES.
THEY'RE WORKING ON CORPORATIONS
LIKE AIRLINES.
WITH REGARDS TO THEIR EMPLOYEES
GETTING VACCINATED.
SO WHETHER YOU LIKE PEOPLE TO
DO IT ON THEIR OWN, OF COURSE,
SOMETIMES MANDATES ACTUALLY CAN
HELP IN THAT REGARD.
AS A SENSITIVE ISSUE IS THAT IT
IS THAT WE ARE REALLY GETTING
PEOPLE MORE VACCINATED.
>> AS YOU KNOW, BURKE HAS JUST
AS THE FDA TO AUTHORIZE ITS NEW
COVID TREATMENT BILL.
THIS COULD BE POTENTIALLY VERY
GOOD NEWS, BUT ARE YOU
CONCERNED THAT AMERICANS ARE
GOING TO RELY ON THIS TREATMENT
AS A SUBSTITUTE FOR VACCINATION?
>> WELL, WE'VE HEARD TALK ABOUT
THAT, WOLF.
I HOPE WE DON'T COME TO THAT
BECAUSE THAT WOULD REALLY, I
THINK, BE A MISUNDERSTANDING
ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT IT IS NOT
TO GET INFECTED.
THE DATA ON THAT DRUG IS
PROMISING.
YOU KNOW IT'S A 50% DIMINUTION,
AND PLACEBO AND
HOSPITALIZATIONS AND DEATHS.
THAT'S GOOD NEWS.
BUT THE BEST WAY TO GET 100
PERCENT, CHANCE OF NOT GETTING
HOSPITALIZATIONS GOING IS TO
NOT GET INFECTED IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
THAT IS BETTER THAN ANY DRUG.
SO ALTHOUGH WE ARE PLEASED AND
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT THIS DRUG,
WHICH IS NOW APPLYING FOR
EMERGENCY USE AUTHORIZATION,
WHICH WOULD NOT BE A SUBSTITUTE
FOR PREVENTING INFECTION IN THE
FIRST PLACE, WHICH IS WHY WE
GET VACCINES.
>> IT IS SO SIMPLE.
IF YOU GET THE SHOT, IT'S
REALLY EASY, EVEN IF APPROVED,
IT'S GONNA BE AWHILE TO SEE IF
IT REALLY REALLY WORKS, GIVEN
THAT THE TRIAL THAT'S BEEN
GOING ON SO FAR.
LET'S TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHAT ELSE IS GOING ON, BECAUSE
THERE'S A LOT OF CRITICAL
ISSUES THAT WE ARE DISCUSSING.
FDA ADVISERS ARE MEETING THIS
WEEK, AS YOU KNOW, TO CONSIDER
MATCHING AND MATHS-ING MOOSE 2
DOSES FROM A DIFFERENT VACCINE.
SHOULD AMERICANS BE ALLOWED,
DOCTOR FAUCI, TO MIX AND MATCH
THEIR BOOSTER?
>> THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT YOU
SAID.
HE ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO THE
FDA IS GONNA LOOK AT THAT DATA
THIS WEEK.
THE NEXT FEW DAYS, THE 14TH AND
THE 15TH OF OCTOBER, AND THEN
THE FOLLOWING WEEK, THAT KIND
OF REGULATORY DECISION WILL BE
HANDED OVER TO THE ADVISORY
COMMITTEE ON IMMUNIZATION
PRACTICES FOR THE CDC.
AND SOMETIME IN THE FIRST
COUPLE OF DAYS OF NOVEMBER, WE
VERY LIKELY WILL GET A
RECOMMENDATION FROM THE CDC.
SO YOU'RE ASKING ME, IS IT
GOING TO BE APPROVED?
WELL, LET'S WAIT AND SEE AFTER
THE DATA ARE EXAMINED, WHICH
YOU'RE QUITE RIGHT IN THE NEXT
FEW DAYS, OR WEEK WE'RE GONNA
BE HEARING MORE ABOUT IT
BECAUSE THE COMPANIES ARE GONNA
BE PRESENTING BOTH MODERNA AND
J&J, WE'RE GONNA BE PRESENTING
THE DATA TO THE FDA FURTHER
ADVISORY COMMITTEE TO LOOK AT.
>> SHOULD BE GETTING THAT
INFORMATION LATER THIS WEEK.
DOCTOR FAUCI, WERE NEARLY 9
MONTHS INTO THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION, AND THE FDA IS
STILL BEING LED BY AN ACTING
DIRECTOR.
HOW DOES THAT MAKE ANY SENSE
THAT IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
PANDEMIC, THE FDA DOESN'T HAVE
A PERMANENT DIRECTOR IN PLACE?
NO ONE HAS EVEN BEEN NOMINATED
FOR THAT CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
POSITION!
>> WELL, I MEAN, OBVIOUSLY
WHENEVER YOU HAVE AN AGENCY OF
THIS IMPORTANCE, YOU WANT TO
HAVE A PERMANENT DIRECTOR.
BUT THE FDA IS DOING FINE.
I MEAN, THE ACTING DIRECTOR
DOCTOR JANET WOODCOCK IS DOING
A VERY GOOD JOB RIGHT NOW,
LEADING THE AGENCY.
AND THE AGENCY IS STRONG.
THEY HAVE PROFESSIONALS IN
THERE THAT HAVE BEEN THERE FOR
A VERY LONG PERIOD OF TIME.
SO IT ISN'T AS IF IS IN
TROUBLE.
THE FACT IS WE WOULD LIKE,
OBVIOUSLY, AS SOON AS WE
POSSIBLY CAN TO GET A FULL-TIME
PERMANENT DIRECTOR.
BUT PEOPLE SHOULD NOT LOOK UP
ON THE FTA